marcus aurelius was the stoic emperor
marcus aurelius was at the top of the
dominance hierarchy of his time and his
authority exerted respect not just
because of his power but also because of
his philosophy that is something very
crucial to ponder the archetype of the
emperor as it has been portrayed
throughout time is usually that of the
oppressor or the narcissist or the
totalitarian marcus aurelius convulses
the foundations of that archetype he was
heavily influenced by epictitus rusticus
and heraclitus and one can notice a more
forward-looking and conclusive
philosophy in his aphorisms the
happiness of your life depends upon the
quality of your thoughts everything we
hear is an opinion not a fact everything
we see is a perspective not the truth if
you are distressed by anything external
the pain is not due to the thing itself
but to your estimate of it and this you
have the power to revoke at any moment
it is not death that a man should fear
but you should fear never beginning to
live